a pivot Philippines's though I don't
have three dimensions my option get it
for that back leg goes straight back
your chest baked in rain do the messes
with two dimensions if I get on to it
[Music]
put down three then brings out some you
already in panic mode
[Music]
no one gets everything correctly you're
also swinging that foot around got it
down as a single pivot point
[Music]
we dimensions mine
there's got to be three dimensions to
your hard work your energies relaxing
you have to have it put your eyes on the
inside like 20 months and everyone's too
high
it's kind of like that
[Music]
so what's your cosmetic chemist and
there's no more fighting capacity of it
this is a huge balancing routine here
here so you can move you see I'm doing
that so i doing i'm doing tight on that
though I don't want to take myself out
do you see
boom okay mmm hey trying it don't get
all that tightrope Brown is the top part
of your head pop the pop your head on
the top of your head
too far late I depart
[Music]
get off that hydro make it a little
wider even your projection stance cannot
be shot all your load it's good to be
ready to miss they have to be ready to
move again your narrow foot like your
chest caved in yet it's because your
Chindi too narrow
you notice then - hi - step in the lower
legs and knees you tilting again when
you turn three dimensions when you have
worked with three dimensions
[Music]
okay so i'll philosophize class we're
going to try to help ourselves get the
skills so he's going to do a push you
see that my first is I'm not going to
necessary that's going to be a straight
line you understand so I'm going to
curve he's here and I'm curving at the
same time that I'm curving I'm relaxing
that so he's pushing I don't want to get
in that fight with him but I also don't
want my flesh to to be tense my flesh is
going to relax okay and just just and
relaxing the flesh you starting to get
that slippery angle do you see that you
see so I use all that news coming in and
I relax the flesh and I heal my hands
are just gonna I don't care where you
put your hands for that and you have to
make sure when you put your hands that
you don't tense back up that part of
these tension that part stays relaxed
alright let's try
don't turn away from your hands though I
do care that you lose biomechanics body
mechanics we went dead we're gonna put
your hands somewhere that part is
relaxing if you like download that
little second that little centimeter
that's what I want then my hands will go
so much and that dead okay but our
bodies
some things I'm doing as you can see I'm
looking at the elbows aren't but don't
you see that is if you check a lot
punches you have it right you have your
hooks talked about all your broccoli
maybe want to tie the elbows you went
too far
[Music]
watch my feet and actually my possessing
how this test yet there's too much
tension at the contact point
too much tension at the contact
so you guys
[Music]
you see that even before that that was
your little attempt to do that
say you felt that you felt the loss of
friction and you put pressure on your
thumb so that see how she had to adjust
to get it yeah that means I'm action and
she's reaction that means we're in a
relationship with each other okay right
now you don't have that and you guys are
going like that so you're bringing back
on earth means you have tension on that
spot like that
and look how we're gonna stay here all
day because I've created friction right
it's struggle there and then you go like
this and I actually I'm pulling apart
from you if you pay attention we're on
the other one is relaxed
even there's your thumb again do you
feel like you're trying to get it with
it and I haven't seen so my hands are
here and I'm relaxing I'm not going like
that I first relaxed that part I have
her she did it again so look I can get
it there I'm how many change directions
on her yeah
so I yield unyielding she's now pushing
this way do you feel that okay so they
need everything okay but for now let's
not be so reactive okay you're a single
energy go on that way that's it
you're not doing this stuff you're not
doing this okay we want people to test
the relaxation you will slip in other
words okay I'm here and I'm relaxing
that and that that was it that little
tiny bit with no movement yet tiny bit
there it is we'll go back watch your
body you see that gives me the
connection and I want okay try to get
hey you have to try your best not to
pull away you want to almost press in
psychologically you can step with that
other foot forward right foot forward
right foot that's your left
[Music]
get your hands up
so when I go here I'm not going to keep
going you see how I'd lost body tags I
said he pushes you're not fishing there
show my chest I want the flesh to
release okay flesh releases the
connection point is here both that's
where you have deep do you understand
tactically so there's if that's the case
then extending this to here is
ridiculous okay we just want this part
you're turning all that way because you
don't have connect you need not going
through and you have to keep turning to
get them to go past you like you see
groaning going past don't go laughs
[Music]
thanks runner bend your knee load your
Center
howlite guys so let's really wanted to
thumb a little bit about what Virginia
was doing that's what you want
tactically when I create this
relationship then I'm in control and
they now have to bleed on me to keep
their balance you understand and now now
I just keep you're not even without it
and you get them okay but some okay more
on the inside will whoa
you understand so you come on out it's
it's still like there's a higher level
skill to fill to feel her thumbs target
organ her starting to chase you you know
jack up your original one which makes
them feel successful but at a higher
level then you got it all you you have
her it's not gonna do anything okay so
that's a better gift for higher level
training and you can won't who feels the
void and I post I'm out of this
there are also higher level training
okay so as I relax I don't want to go
like in and she's trying the hardest not
to be herself right now right right you
know like I'm gonna go in okay but
you're making Virginia having to do that
to you okay just be you so I relax that
you see right right on there push right
on the relax I got by the hover and I
just keep that connection and I keep
relaxing watch yours work Virginia
you're gonna push her with this hand and
instead I'm gonna relax that more you
feel that and actually relaxing
there you stop that's for you that's
where you were you okay now no it's fine
it's fine okay so I'm gonna take my hip
watch and see hey Danny huh
okay so Jewish overhead relax more chill
do it and you'll have another shift
today okay
so technically I always want to control
those elbows
I want to prioritize those when I'm at
Lin level versus the wrist or the
shoulder okay and if I ever have the
wrist
what am I also trying to control his
elbow
the elbow is important so hearing is to
push here that hand is checking that
that arms swing that arm wherever you
want right good okay
again you don't have a little laser
fence right
you're like mm-hmm you want to clock me
okay so when I go here just lay there
for our drill don't do that you're going
to tense that just it's laying there
it's not elbow up just laying there then
as I'm doing the maneuver I'm not gonna
clear it off I'm gonna do the this part
this part is cleared off right and then
I'm looking for the other elbow you see
that and when I do the other elbow I'm
not going to push him and give him back
his balance keep him falling here just
here but I'm looking for it
you guys are so preoccupied with this
you're not aware of that other hand so
one boom boom and I'm actually now
setting up that arm that's all I'm
looking for right so boom I set it up
this is the Armando somewhere realign my
face you see but I'm not turning like
that we're disconnected in boom cases to
that time you just connected on that
step height so if you get him falling
his arm will come out
[Music]
if you make it fall you will give their
balance back time if you get stuck like
what you're trying to enjoy that means
they're using you for balance
don't avoid what she'd want
[Music]
your circular angle of daeviation is
going to work much better for connection
than your linear wanst okay so guess
what
so when i'm dv/dt see this is straight
it's generally straight so this
deviation is curving you see that
usually if you're using the straight
angle deviation it's because you're
going to put a circle in elsewhere okay
but this drill you only get one step so
do a circle and not a linear deviation
you need the circle to unite we're going
to use the gravity and the orbital
nature of the circle to unite so you got
one of you guys you guys already already
solved that riddle it's gonna be the
same every time
so that's ready with depth issues falls
into that hey that's it lace that steps
not in harmony with there
so what's some of the peculiar things
about my stress work and your your
footwork right now I'm going here right
whoa you see how I'm able just to walk I
know I don't need the Bracy name I don't
need that but that's what doesn't need
to push me right because I'm not going
to push him I am related to him
where I'm this year when I enter for the
for a throw it's not going to be moved
there he's not all the way off balanced
you see a little muffin that's what
we're working away
eh I'm okay far away
[Music]
if you can't walk it's because you're
not moving into free space hey you're
early or late or you have the wrong back
there
[Music]
get the other hand an elbow
so you can be our test naga trainers by
being our birthing kit or you could also
work on your Kimi right
[Music]
for example if you don't drop there if
you don't drop your Center you don't add
the third dimension right there head is
not coming down this low understand why
does everyone understand what if you
don't read then okay and okay so I am
only using two dimensions so you're like
you're not doing the line okay but
you're doing a flat circle do you see
that wouldn't want to do a sphere you
see I'm doing that there's a dropper
than that okay and so watch your head
watch your head okay and when her head
goes like that right I go here like that
you're gonna see how that farm come to
that hand yeah and when you don't when
you do this you're gonna have to do that
because that are makes no sense to this
side of your body
you understand so you're going like that
and you're like totally satisfied with
this circle didn't care but you don't
have that though okay try to get
I gently throwing one side of her so to
speak so you could be something with the
other half
[Music]
they in the dance the second step
disconnected right
[Music]
since I'm just a bit
don't lose don't lose the harvester if
I'm doing it I can come and I can go not
one or the other he's baffled you that's
not good to be back okay so when I come
here look how I stopped you your movie
too early is what's happened you're
getting greedy you're going like this
and you go or you got them falling on
you like says let's see how he's got
that angle right there
do you see that do you guys see that and
saying he changed that he's bringing
that side forward that's one reason to
keep that side going with disarm okay
but he got that and then you go on like
this
you think and he does not lose his
balance so we have our ekeus who are
chasing us right and like just keep it
relaxed you might have to change thing I
had he does that again right you might
have to take this arm off so you open
that up even more right or or catch this
early right look you see how you're
doing that but again so we're seeing all
of this stuff we're seeing that okay
who's freaking out you can't just stick
so we stick have one lesson plan this is
not a bad thing your training August but
now yes you have no clue you're
confounding them okay
then we have our our aggressive people
right who are like oh yeah I'll get you
that's not what happens
sorry if I if I were to push you you're
gonna grapple me what do you think you
gonna say so wait wait when you're doing
your
what you think is a projection as US I
didn't need to do the projection he was
already following you get it that's what
your projection happened your projection
doesn't happen here and you go like that
people will not fall your your
projection is down here okay let's find
out then you gotta get them fall and all
we need is you can see don't fall you
shouldn't need to fall you do have a
projection for height that will test
whether we have connection all the way
through or not right that's a push we
don't have a connection
[Music]
what what is connection what is what's
supposed to happen here
that's Aikido t-shirt yes okay but how
do I get projection in a Nike art what's
happening so on the sides to see wow
that really helps long way to listen go
okay there's that
that's not projection that's falling I'm
going to accelerate the fall with the
force you see that an additional force
that's projection how is that force
originated what is the mechanism of that
force no oh my gosh that's the exact
officer initial intent no okay what do I
do with that you don't have your arms
movements separately okay
I don't I you guys are terrible at this
what do they hit yes with the end what
do they hit at the beginning of this
ball nothing geez
let's go box a lottery the guy does this
pushes right and I can do that
that's a push I could do this projection
or what I did you go what if it what
happened describe it I came in and then
I just hit he did a wall what's making
the wall of course it's me what about me
hi say without me this santuario sun
card that's a that's an Ikea t-shirt to
me what the hell does that mean your
body - such let's go longer in the
desert go
[Music]
come on get your head down lower so some
bootcamp on some rats when you get hit
try not to fall translate it into what
don't come in you see that come in less
but the rules of the game lawyer you're
gonna push yeah well fine again higher
docket level fine keen okay you have the
initial one boom but you gotta have your
pet you can doing this signs house so
you come play with these forces so watch
your kami right you're like don't fall
would I be here is don't go it's easier
for me to fall into the trip or stumble
don't do that but you still have to do
that there you go hey if they don't come
in hit them
[Music]
that's not coming in so just so you you
can understand like this kind of how
positions to ego and it into training
you want you want to win the contest
even though there's no contest right and
so it looks like why do I want to set
myself up you get what I'm saying I'm
here buddy
Thurston come in right and you have the
opposite reality you have the wrong
reality right the full-blown thing the
full blast that you think is setting you
up is the harder one to deal with
what are you ready do you understand
that's much harder to deal with
anyway you
you